[Music]
world aids day this year
finds us deep in the throes of another
pandemic
kovit 19. the highly infectious novel
coronavirus has swept across the world
devastating health systems and causing
economic
turmoil
[Music]
not since the hiv aids pandemic of the
1990s have countries face such a common
health threat
around 33 million people worldwide have
died from aids-related illnesses in the
last 40 years
it's taken expertise collaboration and
dedication
from all levels of society to track
understand
treat and prevent the illness
although hiv aids hasn't been eradicated
the global response is an example of
what can be achieved
when countries and people work together
this is dw's covert 19 special i'm kate
ferguson thanks for joining me
once upon a time an hiv diagnosis was
seen as a death sentence
those days are now gone with advances in
treatment allowing people to live
long and rich lives but challenges do
remain especially amid
a global pandemic that's seen the supply
of hiv drugs in some parts of the world
severely disrupted around the world
there are some 38 million people
living with hiv last year alone some 1.7
million new infections were recorded and
690
000 people lost their lives to the
disease
people living with hiv are especially
vulnerable during this pandemic
for one they're more at risk of falling
severely ill with covet 19
but perhaps even more crucially as the
coronavirus shuts economies down
many sufferers have not been able to
access
medication you can visit
it's a very welcome arrival employees of
the north star alliance deliver hiv
drugs to the godwana settlement
west of johannesburg
the risk of becoming seriously or even
fatally ill with covert 19
is twice as high for hiv-positive people
many are avoiding overcrowded hospitals
for fear of infection
however interrupting treatment can have
serious consequences
unaids expects up to 148 000 additional
hiv
deaths related to the coronavirus
pandemic by 2022
especially in poor regions
the greatest number of people with hiv
live in africa
more than 25 million in sub-saharan
africa
twice the rest of the world put together
sibongile zulu is a single mother of
four children in johannesburg
her clinic ran out of drugs during the
hard lockdown in the spring
on top of this the 47 year old lost her
job
for two months she had to do without
half the medicine she needs
she's now receiving support from a
christian aid organization
northstar alliance is trying to get
close to the needs of the most
vulnerable people
using mobile clinics this kind of
assistance helps save many lives
but the world health organization says
more is needed
more financial aid but also the
commitment that the battle against hiv
aids is fought with the same
determination
as the fight against the coronavirus
pandemic
let's speak to professor jurgen
rochester president of the european aids
clinical society he's joining us today
from bonn professor rochette welcome
along
how disruptive has the covert covid19
pandemic been for people living with hiv
aids
yes i think it's very different from
country to country there have been
surveys
in various parts of europe suggesting
that at least 50 percent of the
physicians are involved in hiv care also
manage the covet patients so obviously
they have two diseases to serve and as
such there have been disruptions
uh in our own clinic we closed the
clinic for two months
in april and may and just sent out
prescriptions i think the biggest
challenge has been for testing
services uh because of the issue you
can't go and have contact other people
and from the lockdown a lot of people
were not able
to assess the usual testing frequency
and that's one of the big worries
around missing hiv diagnosis because
people
cannot go to the adequate testing
services
and how dangerous is covert 19 itself
for hiv patients
yeah so that has been an ongoing
discussion because obviously people with
hiv have
often immune deficiency depending on
their level of cd4 count
and as such may be at an increased risk
for any kind of infection
and so there was some worry that they
may have a different course of disease
the first case reports though from north
america china
and europe suggested that really the
outcome was very similar so it doesn't
really look as if the mortality was
enhanced or
increased there has been a more recent
larger
cohort analysis and i think that's one
of the issues if you only look at small
patient numbers you may miss something
because the patients average were much
younger
than some of the patients who had a more
unfavorable disease outcome
and in africa there was a 2.6 fold
higher mortality there also has been a
higher mortality
reported for hiv patients from the uk
around 1.6 fold higher
so i think in summary it looks as if in
general it's pretty much the same
outcome but if you have a low cd4 count
below 200 and you're severely moon
compromised i think that's where
you may have a more increased risk
but overall much health is low and i can
say from my own clinic we've seen 10
patients with
copic 19 and hiv and none of them was
admitted to intensive care none of them
died so
i think in general in the younger
patient population not so worrisome but
if you are older with comorbidities and
as an hiv patient you have a higher risk
for comorbidities
then i think there is a somewhat
increased risk okay
now we're very close to having several
vaccines against covid19
why is there still no vaccine against
hiv
yeah so 2020 was unfortunately a year
were a vaccine which had showed some
promise
in the thai vaccine trial where there
was a 33 reduction in
infections and now this improved vaccine
was tested in south africa and
unfortunately the trial was stopped
because of
the lack of seat and i think the reasons
is that
hiv employs the shield technology and
the virus is constantly changing its
shield to protect itself
uh and these changes sort of evade a
vaccine attempt so it's not so easy to
target hiv
and that's a little different than some
of the other viruses have less
changes in their surface so
the united nations has set itself the
goal of ending the aids epidemic by
2030. do you think that's realistic
well you know on a more positive side if
you look at some of the recent
numbers from the uk you can see that
actually they're very close to ending
the epidemic because they have
uh more than 95 percent of their
patients are diagnosed who have hiv at
least in the london region
they have more than 95 percent on
treatment and they have more than 95
percent
uh virally biologically suppressed so
they're doing very well
and the new numbers are falling really
quite dramatically and it's really great
to see
that with the tools we have to end the
epidemic if you can use them that's all
working very well
but if you turn your eyes a little bit
to the east and you move to russia for
example
which obviously has a much higher
patient burden with over 800 000
infected individuals
and only probably around 55 percent
receiving antiviral therapy
there remains a large pool of people who
are
either not diagnosed or replicating and
kind of such infect other patients so
the question is how can we get all these
tools we have
implemented everywhere in the world and
obviously also now in the covet epidemic
where there's suddenly a struggle for
resources from one side to the other
physicians are engaged in services for
two diseases at the same time
the disruption of services on many
different layers stock out of arv
happening in many african countries
will obviously put a big hazard to the
goals which have been set up
and the accomplishments although
theoretically at least are good examples
in clinical practice where these goals
seem
reachable so some hope there jurgen
rochester president of the european aids
clinical society thank you very much
pleasure time now to answer one of your
questions about covid19
over to our science correspondent derek
williams
what makes sars ko v2 different from the
sars virus
is it the same pathogen just stronger
no although this common question shows
how much power there is
in a name the international body
that's responsible for naming newly
discovered viruses
decided to call the one that causes
covet 19
sars cove 2 because it's fairly closely
related to the one that caused the
respiratory disease sars back in the
early 2000s
but although there are similarities in
some of the symptoms that the two
pathogens cause
they're not the same and sars cove ii
did not arise from the virus that causes
sars a genetic analysis is placed both
in a group of what are called
lineage b beta coronaviruses which
also includes a number of other
coronaviruses that are found in bats
a major characteristic that better
coronaviruses share
is that they infect mammals which means
they exploit the similarities that all
mammal cells have in common
to to invade them and and make more
copies of virus and sometimes they jump
from species to species the three betta
coronaviruses that have jumped
to humans to cause recent outbreaks
the pathogens that are responsible for
sars
and and mers and covet 19 they've all
caused
respiratory symptoms and fevers but in
other ways
like the timing of the disease that they
induce and
and its overall lethality that differs
widely sars was much more deadly than
covet 19 for example but
but because people who got it only began
infecting others after they started
showing symptoms themselves
it could be contained more easily soros
cove too
is not stronger than the virus that
caused sars
and it's not the same it's it's just a
cousin that's turned out
to be a lot better at spreading in human
populations and
and though it can also be deadly if you
catch it
covet 19 is actually a lot less likely
to kill you than sars was
you